[Applaudissements]
j'avais le plus bel amandier du
quartier j'avais le plus bel amandier du
quartier et pour la bouche gourmande des
filles du monde entier je faisais
pousser des amandes le beau le joli
métier un écureil en jupon dans un bon
un écureuil en jupon dans un bon V me
dire je suis gourmande et mes lèvres
sentent bons et si tu me donnes une
amande je te donne un baiser
[Musique]
fripon grimpe aussi que tu veux que tu
peux grimpe aussi que tu veux que tu
peux et tu croques et tu picor puis tu
grignotes et puis tu redescends plus
vite encore me donner le baiser
du quand la belle tout rongé tout mangé
quand la belle tout rangé tout
mangé je te pai me dit-elle à pleine
bouche quand les nigos seront pourvu
d'elle et que tu sauras
voler monte m'embrasser si tu veux si tu
peux monte-moi brasser si tu veux si tu
peux mais dis-toi que si tu tombes je
n'aurai pas la larme à l'œil dis-toi que
si tu succombes je ne porterai pas le
deuil les avait bien entendu toutes
mordu les avait bien entendu toute
mordue toute grignoté mes amandes ma
récolte était perdue mais sa jolie
bouche gourmande en baisé m'a tout
rendu et la fête du Ratan que le BE
temps et la fête du R tan que le beau
temps mais V l'automne et la foudre et
la pluie et les a temps ont changé mon
arbre en poudre et mon amour amène
[Musique]
p